welcome to season two of Tucker Carlson
Originals about a year and a half ago a
group of producers and I sat down at
dinner and talked about how to go a
little deeper into some of the topics we
cover on the nighttime show wouldn't it
be interesting to spend more than three
and a half minutes on a subject that
matters to our viewers wouldn't it be
cool to make documentaries the only
problem is cable news companies don't
make documentaries they make cable news
and they do a pretty good job we think
but we went to Fox News and asked could
we do this into our amazement and
Delight they said yes you can and so for
the last year we have made a series of
long-form documentaries about issues
that we think matter to the country and
to you and they've worked better than we
ever expected we're proud of what we've
created so we're doing another season
and for a preview of that we are joined
by the Diabolical genius behind the
curtain The Man Behind all this our
senior executive producer Justin Wells
who's the vice president here at Fox
News Justin Wells good to see you on
camera for the first first time in a
long time last year that's last year um
so
this has become something that we I
think it's fair to say did not expect it
to become at all we knew we wanted to do
it and we knew Fox was supporting us and
going out there telling stories that no
one's telling we went to at least 30
States we went to several countries and
we got a lot of support from the
audience because they were not able to
consume this anywhere else and we you
know rattled a few people in the
mainstream Media or whatnot obviously
because
you know perhaps some of the stories are
controversial but they're topics that
people care about deeply and you
actually need to spend time dissecting
them and understanding them and that's
what we do in these documentaries
they're shot beautifully you know we've
got the best team as far as that but the
team that does the nightly show knows
what stories matter to people they're
part of this and that's why I think it
worked
um and you hate to suck up to your
employer I see people all the time
sucking up to their employers they work
for these horrible big companies force
them to read the propaganda and they do
I resent all of that but I have to say
Fox News has gone all in in support of
this some of the stuff that we've
produced has not been popular with like
NBC and CNN
and you would know since you deal with
it but fox has stood behind us
completely 100 and there hasn't been a
single time where they've told us to
talk about this don't talk about that or
go and cover that story or don't cover
that sir we we say this is what we're
doing this season
um we've decided to go to Hungary and
we're going to really investigate how
they took a different approach to George
Soros and dive into that and see how
maybe we could learn something here in
America and we did that on our own and
you know they've given us the resources
to have and you know the New York Times
didn't love that we were there for a
week investigating how they take a
different approach to their country we
we somehow ended up in Serbia by
accident on that trip you know a few
surprises along the way but
um you know I think that's what makes
this series different I think that's why
it's resonated with people that's why
we're able to go out for season two
cover even more topics uh that are
equally going to be as insightful as
what we did in the first season but
nobody's talked about some of these
nobody's talking about testosterone
boundaries a little bit it's a little
weird to wake up at 52 and realize you
work for the last stronghold of free
speech in all mass media I did not
expect that when I started working here
13 years ago I don't think you did
either but that's really where we work
the last place where you can say what
you think is true and your bosses will
back you up so why is this season better
well I think the season's better first
of all it's on Fox Nation and you know
if we were doing this on YouTube or some
other Outlet or whatever they'd be
banning we wouldn't be able to view it
yes when you go there you can sign up
and you're going to get everything from
testosterone levels which you're going
to hear later in the hour last season we
covered UFOs and that phenomenon and uh
you know we dived into cattle
mutilations a little bit but this season
we really are investigating that
fine-tune you know approach to to what's
actually happening yeah because it's the
perfect story for this series because
it's one of those things that you hear
about and you think well that can't be
that's too crazy to be real you ask
questions about a shut up conspiracy
monger and then you get a little deeper
into it and you ask like what the hell
is this and and I think that we did that
we did and there's some guys that are
going to be on later this hour that are
going to demonstrate why what we're
looking at is it can't be you know
humans just going there and like people
do not you know take cows and mutilate
them randomly on farms there no at scale
massive scale yep so Justin Wells and
I'm gonna wreck your life by saying this
but this is The Man Behind all these
different products so we thought you
should say hi to him again thank you for
that thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight